now as many as three quarters of all new
coronavirus infections across the uk
involved the
so-called indian variant and the health
secretary matt hancock says that the
number of new cases
is rising again throughout the country
that rising rate of infection is
casting doubt on whether the government
really can lift remaining
restrictions on june the 21st
public health expert professor linda
bold joins us from edinburgh
professor bold you heard what the
minister has to say
um does that sound like we are heading
to
end of lockdown on june 21st to you
i think it's very ambitious trevor
looking at the national picture
the average seven-day average for cases
at the moment is well over three
thousand
if you look back just to the first week
of may we were around two thousand
and in some parts of the country
including parts here in scotland
we've seen a big increase and i know
that's not translating yet
to large numbers of people in hospital
but there are more people in hospital
particularly those in midlife who may
only have had one dose of the vaccine
so looking ahead the 21st of june is
very soon
and i think to avoid more preventable
deaths that you've just been discussing
with the minister
we really need to be cautious at the
current time
so you actually if you i know that
you're not in the policy territory but
if you had your way
you would actually have to be positively
uh
convinced that opening on june the 21st
is safe before you follow the roadmap as
it currently is which is to lift all
restrictions after that date
that's correct and i think even from
policy colleagues including in the
developed nations we've been hearing
very cautionary
messages and that we can't commit to
towards the end of june that the
summer solstice date i really think that
it's too early
to be charging ahead i would like to see
several more weeks data and the kind of
evidence i want to see
and all my colleagues is that these uh
chains of transmission these
links between the fact that we always
knew we'd have slightly more cases when
we opened
up but it's moving through the system to
then
people becoming unwell we don't want
anyone to become severely unwell
with this virus and we've really got
just over four in ten
of the population who've got good
protection from both doses other
countries
final point on this that have opened up
fully like israel
have many more in their population that
have got full protection from the
vaccines and we're just not there yet
but um professor baldwin your
distinguished expert in behavioral
science amongst other
things
changing the signals which at the moment
say we're heading towards opening do you
think
we're not israel do you think that
britain would respond
well to that or are we now at risk of
creating a situation where a population
has been relatively compliant
seeing its summer holidays slipping away
underneath lockdown might start to
revolt
well there's two points there the first
one is yes the gov the the public are
totally fed up
everybody just wants things to go back
to normal or most things to go back to
normal
i think we recognize that and there is
frustration
but the government said particularly the
uk government said data not dates
and so i think they really do need to
follow the data and as i say at the
moment the situation
is is not entirely moving in the right
direction
on compliance we heard from dominic
cummings uh criticism
of behavioral scientists including on
spy b at the beginning of the pandemic
saying there would be behavioral
fatigue that didn't come from my
colleagues on spy b
and actually the british public the
levels of adherence and compliance have
been
truly astonishing and when you look at
the latest data some of the surveys that
have been done
there's a significant portion of the
population who are still very very
concerned
recognize that we shouldn't be rushing
ahead and so i don't think we're going
to see writing on the streets despite
the fact that we have had demonstrations
around vaccines etc
that's a small proportion what most
people in this country want
is not not more people to die to be able
to move ahead
and with more confidence and to know
that we're not going to have to take
backwards steps and go
back into local or national restrictions
nobody wants that
so forgive me i i missed a second what
you were saying but i might to
understand that you
actually think that what mr cummings now
says
he said at the time which was harder
faster
lockdown quicker was correct i think so
i mean i do have sympathy for some of
the decisions taken very early on in the
pandemic when we didn't know about
airborne transmission
and we didn't know so much about
asymptomatic transmission etc and a
number of countries in europe didn't act
quickly enough
and i think you know cummings evidence i
mean it was really shocking listening to
that and it will all be poured over
and i don't think we should you know be
necessarily making judgments now about
what he said that was correct and wasn't
correct but i think a lot of things he
said about decisions that were taken
that could have prevented such a big
second wave
and things we should have learned around
travel around ventilation
around moving cautiously protecting
particular groups
you know we're still not necessarily
being that cautious and using that
evidence so i think some of what he said
we really do need to learn from not in a
future public inquiry next year but
learn from now
well of course that's important now at
the heart of much of what we're doing
now is the relationship between
politics and science and i just want to
ask you because i'm interested in this
uh as a scientist the government's been
saying from the start of this that
it has been and will be guided by the
science
listening to dominic cummings and
watching from your own experience in
your own participation
do you think that's actually what
happened not entirely no i mean
first of all there's no single signs
scientists always disagree
and then the consensus needs to be
reached but it's very clear
you know we were delayed in getting the
sage paper so we can now all pour over
them
and it's clear at several points in the
pandemic the government didn't follow
the advice of sage
including the behavioral science advice
that's very clear but looking back to
the autumn recommendations around taking
early action in september those were not
taken so i don't think the government
has always followed the signs i think
it's completely incorrect to say
that's the case in some aspects they
have in some aspects they haven't
and the final point i would make there
is that one of the things
trevor to me that's most regrettable
about the last 14 months
is that governments have often blamed
the public
for things that have gone wrong the
public's behavior and just going back to
the data i was referring to
you know the public have suffered
they've tried their absolute best
and i think you know government needs to
take responsibility for for what's
occurred
professor ball thank you so much you'll
know that we'll return to this
many many times